security and defense editor debra haynes
now reports from keith a warning that
her report does contain some distressing
scenes
the brutality of russia's war revealed
as its troops retreat from around kiev
bodies left lying in the street in the
town of butcher
nearby this airbase was a day one target
that was never achieved
russian forces also beaten back from the
battleground town of erpin
in fact ukraine says its troops have
retaken control of the entire kiev
region a significant moment after more
than five weeks of fighting but russia
is accused of leaving behind deadly
minds as it refocuses on the south and
east
in kiev's main children's hospital
evidence of this country's deep scars
a russian attack on sophia's village
last month left a piece of shrapnel the
size of a peanut embedded in the
thirteen-year-old's brain
[Music]
this is what doctors saw when sofia was
transferred to their care last week the
jagged chunk of metal penetrated her
skull and stopped in the middle of her
brain
a tube is also visible to drain away
fluid
in a delicate operation one of ukraine's
top neurosurgeons removed the shrapnel
to avoid infection
it's really miracle
when the bullet going through their head
did it make a big hemorrhage
and stop
near
the very
important structures
just one centimeter before one above
one centimeter below one centimeter
back
everything
very important that's the drainage this
was the shrapnel how did you feel when
you got the shrapnel out
nice make a photo
sophia came here for surgery from the
southern city of nikolayev hundreds of
miles away after a three-week wait
uh
her daughter's recovering in the
hospital basement safer from the threat
of russian attacks here she dreams about
returning home and learning to play the
guitar a dream they're determined to
realize
debrahing sky news keefe